[Musique]
le but partout c'est de désorganiser au
maximum la production et si la question
c'est de savoir si on veut mettre à
genoux l'économie française la réponse
elle est oui dans les airs 20 à 30% des
vols pourraient être déprogrammés mardi
et mercredi à cause du manque de
contrôleurs aériens sur le rail intrins
sur cinq en moyenne devrait rouler
trafic très perturbé aussi à la RATP
avec une grève reconductible on sait
qu'on commence mardi l'idée c'est de
s'arrêter une fois qu'on aura obtenu le
retrait je me suis dit à la retraite
quand j'aurai je serai en retraite je
viendrai au 12 coups et c'est ce que
j'ai fait
alors qu'est-ce que vous faisiez comme
boulot j'ai travaillé à la SNCF
là je sais qu'il y a la fête des
grands-mères qui arrivent bientôt
n'hésitez pas à offrir une jolie tasse
un joli mug ça fait toujours plaisir et
en plus bah pour nos amis c'est des gros
souvenirs qui a garderont à vie
une mamie qui roule vite qui écoute de
la musique moderne mais c'est pas une
mamie il faudrait que ça soit comment
une mamie ça fait des confitures avec un
chignon alors j'ai une autre petite
fille qui m'a dit un jour mais c'était
trop marrant elle m'a dit mamie tu sais
les mamies fait comme toi c'est un peu
des dents en ferraille
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est un peu la peau démolie mais tu
es très jolie quand même et je t'aime
très fort d'autres secteurs sont appelés
à rejoindre la grève mardi comme
l'éducation la métallurgie et la
pétrochimie avec la même promesse une
semaine noire pour le gouvernement
comprenez-vous qu'une majorité de
Français soit toujours opposée à la
réforme des retraites bien sûr on
préfère ne pas travailler
ce que je trouve c'est pas mon domaine
d'expertise mais là où je crois être
compétent c'est cette façon de célébrer
la valeur travail qui me paraît
des arguments du gouvernement du
gouvernement
des partisans de travail n'est pas une
valeur morale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et qui
partirait
qu'est-ce que toutes ces expériences
vous ont appris de la vie ça m'a appris
qu'il faut toujours travailler comme un
chien galeux
comme une petite fourmi je sais pas il
faut travailler avec acharnement et puis
faire en fait faire pour moi c'est
demain et c'est faire tout de suite là
c'est la drogue moi je peux pas vivre
sans ce projet
que je sache s'il n'est pas écrit dans
les évangiles et c'est un athé qui vous
le rappelle il n'est pas écrit
travailler les uns les autres que votre
Père du Ciel travaille il est écrit
aimez-vous les uns les autres contre
Père du Ciel vous aime l'amour était
dans le moral le travail n'en n'est pas
une il est pas écrit au fronton de
nous-mérir travail égalité fraternité il
est écrit liberté égalité fraternité la
liberté est de l'orage le travail n'est
pas une
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le filtre à la mode sur Tik Tok
avec bol de glamour vous obtenez un
visage sans défaut un filtre particulier
car il semble se mélanger à votre visage
même lorsque l'on bouge touche il reste
en place le filtre utilise une
intelligence artificielle bluffant et
inquiétant car il peut créer de nouveaux
complexes selon de nombreux utilisateurs
mais bol de glamour a déjà été utilisé
dans plus de 8 millions de vidéos le TOC
les ruines étaient le décor parfait pour
des plans séquences sur musique triste
en jogging Dior et la soupe offertes
survivants elle a fait philosopher sur
les inégalités dans le monde ici il y a
pas de personnes riches plus pauvres on
est tous les égal il reste parfois des
images cultes des émissions que vous
avez faites et il y en a une
effectivement qui restent très présente
c'est la colère d'Alain Finkielkraut
dans une émission vous vous souvenez
évidemment
en quelle année ça c'est je pourrai pas
vous dire mais je sais que pendant un
certain temps elle a envoyé ses livres
il me les dédicacer de la part de
taisez-vous et il est taisez-vous en
lettres capitales avec un point
d'interrogation ou là où je suis un peu
un peu déçu c'est que je suis venu un
peu trop tard moi j'avais prévu de
rester au moins 10 jours et rester ici
il y a tellement un gros engagement ça
c'est tellement bien organisé que en
fait les gens n'ont pas besoin de
soutien
non non non non laissez le terminer
quand vous dites mets un bouchon dans je
cite oui je cite le dialogué un bouchon
dans ton cul
sur les autres Vincent en plus ça c'est
pas du Molière
si on résume Dylan thierry est allé en
Turquie pour inciter les gens à faire
des dons une fois sur place c'est dit ah
non tranquille c'est bon ils ont pas
besoin d'aide en plus les immeubles vont
se reconstruire tout seul et non
seulement il s'est cassé au bout d'une
journée sans lâcher une tune mais en
plus il a dit aux gens que ça servait à
rien de donner la recommande ça passe à
place ici personne peut faire de la
nature sa petite
les enfants qui peuvent penser comme ça
c'est fini mais je parle la tête haute
les messages à tous les rageux vogue
et Ciao